tu es l'avortement avant que
l'avortement de tu la mairie tu es
l'avortement
c'est l'objectif des anti ivg depuis
plus de 30 ans aux états unis des
personnes qui remettent en cause le
droit des femmes à avorter acquis dans
le pays depuis 1973
les adversaires de l'avortement qui ont
organisé pour le 22 janvier une grande
manifestation à washington ont dit
qu'ils voulaient faire parler d'eux par
tous les moyens au début des années 80
les manifestations anti avortement se
multiplient dans tout le pays une
révolution conservatrice menée et
encouragé par le président républicain
de l'époque ronald reagan
le problème de l'avortement nous irons à
la gorge
est-ce que l'avortement du hall et
humaines ou non est devenu si ça tu
avais que la médecine le monde
de plus il faut l'arrêter et pour
arrêter les avortements certains
n'hésitent pas à employer la manière
forte menace attentat à la bombe
perpétré contre des centres dits vg
mêmes assassinat font partie des
méthodes employées par quelques
fanatiques en 1995 pour se protéger ce
médecin avait dû s'équiper
je ne suis jamais très loin d'une arme
quand des maniaques vos menaces de mort
reste et des armées n'est pas très
judicieux dans les années 90 la pression
constante des pro-vie exercée sur les
cliniques les médecins et les hommes
politiques portent leurs fruits selon
l'institut de recherche américain good
marqueur 1000 établissements pratiquant
l'avortement avaient fermé leurs portes
entre 1992 et 2002 une réalité qui
inquiétait cette féministe en en 2000
j'ai très peur que l'amérique revienne
en arrière
j'espère qu'on perd de nos droits nos
libertés qu'on perde le respect pour les
petites gens aux états unis malgré la
loi de 1973 autorisant l'avortement dans
tout le pays
chaque état a le droit d'apporter des
restrictions modalités de l'ibg un droit
dont certains gouverneurs ne se sont pas
privés
toujours selon l'institut bout de marc
heures depuis plus de 40 ans plus de la
moitié des 50 états américains ont
adopté des mesures restrictives en 2017
les anti ivg en espérait encore plus
grâce à leur nouveau président donald
train un président pro vie qui depuis
son élection a fait entrer deux juges
anti avortement au sein de la cour
suprême des etats unis la plus haute
juridiction du pays à majorité
conservatrice doit d'ailleurs se
prononcer sur les loi très restrictive
sur l'avortement votée récemment en
alabama et dans le missouri
[Musique]